okay but what I'll say about those guys
that are shopping in whorehouses is it
kind of goes back to they didn't do the
work to be in abundance the more simp
guy the more the guy that didn't take
care of his business the guy that's not
in abundance in his life he'll take her
immediately because that's the hottest
girl he can get if you don't have any
abundance you know if this girl that
you've met who maybe you know she's got
some questionable morals or she's not
ideal for you but she's the best that
you've ever got you're gonna cling on to
that like it's your life depends on it
you think you're not gonna cry you're
gonna [__] cry and you're gonna be
upset can I ask you a question so
obviously you mentioned online
um but I genuinely feel like a lot of
men are looking for wives in whole
houses right in whorehouses figuratively
yeah basically you're picking the wrong
woman you're looking for a lot of men
are kind of like going for women just
bumping into them like in the club what
they're looking for where they can find
an easy woman because it may say that
the chase is a lot easier what is the
best physical place for a man to meet a
wife in your opinion physical place yes
in like real life not online ideally it
would be in the gym for me I'm real big
on Fitness like Jim okay but what I'll
say about those guys that are shopping
in whorehouses is it kind of goes back
to they didn't do the work to be in
abundance so
I've slept with a bunch of Instagram
models right I would never never take
them seriously why
because their titties are all over the
Internet and that's that is a problem
it's a big problem yeah I get that
because she didn't keep that secret yeah
but you could cover her up
if she changed the whole account
immediately maybe but that's a big maybe
but if you could do it that means that
the guys probably did it as well isn't
it like in itself right exactly but but
the thing too is this is like so the the
more simp guy the more the guy that
didn't take care of his business the guy
that's not in abundance in his life
he'll take her immediately because
that's the hottest girl he can get yeah
but he's picking the wrong cloth it goes
back to what we talked about earlier
about like what makes a woman look good
for a high level Man online it's being
the right cloth you can show that you're
built well without showing the assets
themselves yeah it's interesting that
you said that he could cover her up
though because if sneako had said that
said oh I could I'll just cover her up
you just said he was misogynist
um
but you're right
ask maybe maybe and maybe they got off
on the on the wrong foot I think some
men have unrealistic standards though in
what way
because you said that you would meet
your ideal partner in the gym so she
could be like a gym or work or anywhere
normal I think what not a club
I think it's not the venue so much I
mean yeah I'd agree not a club but I
think it's not beyond that it's not the
venue so much it's it's does the guy
have a decent vetting system in place
like is he and you're right if you don't
have
any abundance you know if this girl that
you've met who maybe you know she's got
some questionable morals or she's not
ideal for you but she's the best that
you've ever got you're going to cling on
to that like it's your life depends on
it right and actually what you need to
do is have the power not to do that you
know to let a woman go even if she's
incredibly beautiful you know to like
with the instagrammables you know just
let her go because she's not right for
you okay so you and you've got to you've
got a vet you've got to know what you're
looking for and you've got to stick to
those um those boundaries that you have
for yourself so another question for you
too other than obviously the physical
appearance what other ways do you spot
red flags in a woman what's your trick
well how do you filter through what you
say is decent what is not in terms of
like the mentality the things you can't
actually see you've got to look at their
behavior I think yeah like if she's if
she slept with you on the first date are
you not going to take her serious
yeah that's the real thing because we've
I think women feel like a real
attraction and a pool to someone that
you you really like like because in that
time it's that it's an innate behavior
I'll tell you this I have felt women not
sleep with me on a first date knowing
they wanted to just to try to defend
against that and then and I think it's a
smart move I respect it but what what
attracts me just as much as you well not
as much as Beauty I don't think that's
fair but a woman that's level-headed and
based what can we buy that by base so
okay cool
so I just said something that you don't
like right but you're intelligent enough
to have a real conversation and not go
boom Off the Wall can't hear what I'm
saying anymore we can have a real
conversation that's intellectually
attractive that's a smart thing to do
you know what I'm saying like that's how
a woman can like you sit in it it's the
combative women the ones that want to
argue with you and everything's a
problem and then you're like dude I'm
not arguing with you I'm an adult I'm
gonna act like an adult if we can have a
conversation about if you can have hard
conversations with men about hard
subjects and really step back and even
and kind of separate the emotion because
here's the thing let's say you agree to
that and you say with man and you
suspect he's doing something behind your
back right you think you're not gonna
cry you're gonna [__] cry and you're
gonna be upset hopefully there's enough
trust and love in that relationship that
you can bring that pain to him and he's
there to Foster you through it you look
to him to help you through it because
you look up to him because he's there
for you because you trust him because he
has proven himself to you if you can get
there with a man dude I I truly believe
that the chances of divorce at that
point are almost next to nothing also by
the way if you are that type of woman
and I'm not trying to do a campaign for
promoting women to let men cheat but he
ain't gonna leave your ass either
he definitely probably not going to
leave you yeah but they say that men
don't leave their dummies
men don't leave their dummies yeah well
that's your perspective I think those
men probably love those women take care
of him a long time and who's a joke on
because the other women are with the Box
cat the box one and the cats that girl
that girl is probably unobjected to buy
for a family vacation
with her mother on board so you think a
woman is better off staying with a man
that takes care of her provides her and
there for her emotionally and
financially yes and financially than
just leaving and finding because there's
this trend on social media where it's
just like if a person is not treating
you right do you go and walk away do you
think that's perspective no here's
here's the thing
what is the likelihood of finding a man
that can actually take care of you
physically emotionally financially is
very low
that you're attracted to that you look
up to that's building you up it's very
very low
I'll put it to women like this you're
going to leave me for a man that you
love less that's going to cheat on you
anyway yeah
and I don't look I know it sucks I I
swear to God if I could I would write a
check for a million dollars right now I
would be worth 10x more if that feeling
inside of me that that sexual urge as a
man was gone I'd be like life would be
so much more productive
I don't think it's cool I don't think
it's cute I'm not trying to sound like a
big G none of that [__] I'm telling you
honestly I my whole 20s I dealt with the
pain of leaving women I love because I
want to cheat on them cheat on them I
wish I'd have been in a place where I
could have just told him the truth but I
didn't know any better because I was
young
it's in us it's truly in us I don't I
think the best women in the world are
the one not the best women in the world
the best women in the world are the ones
that do their side of the male and
female Dynamic and understand how the
world actually works and if a man cheats
on you yes it's Gonna Hurt you're gonna
cry he should show up for you but I
don't necessarily think you should leave
because finding a man that's going to
take care of you emotionally and
financially and physically is gonna be
hard to come by
you guys another question what do you
think of girls moving to men as in like
the girl making the move and if you like
it how should they do it if you don't
like it why not my Instagram is Justin
when Waller said
okay it happens that it happens all day
all right well I mean for for a wifey
not just because obviously any girl can
slide in your DMs and talk right but
what is a good approach what is a
successful approach for wife and what is
a successful approach for just any girl
sure you wanna take it
so we're talking about for wifey as
opposed to just celebrating the deal but
let's go
let's go man
well I think uh as far as the the wife
thing's concerned I think that she's got
a just in the context of a relationship
she's got to behave in a way that is
gonna make her the most attractive
option that that guy's ever met to
become his wife and the way to do that
is by embodying the characteristics that
that we've discussed so things like you
know modest modesty demuriness you know
being Pleasant to be around not being
combative
showing that she's going to support him
on his mission you know if you're doing
all of those things when in the course
of the dating then what are the best
ways we can support men on their mission
not being competitive I think is one of
them
um but like what's active like what like
like that's that's sort of passive
because it's like not doing something
but what are things that women can like
actively do
I think
um being a stabilizing presence when the
guy come comes back you know I mean
we've talked a lot about cooking and
cleaning and those kinds of things I
mean we've got ubereats now but you know
I think I think those kinds of things
being nurturing being supportive in in
terms of physical tasks what's the most
supportive thing a woman's done for you
um they've cooked for me they've you
know they've made woken me up in the
morning maybe breakfast set out yeah
things like that set out the workspace
so that you know making sure that I'm
ready to have a good day's work you know
sort of just just just really being
there on your team but and not causing
unnecessary stress not causing
unnecessary friction it's those things I
think that that are important
that sounds so beautiful but it's so
crazy how people will say that if you do
that then you're a simp and you're weak
if you make your mind breakfast well
I've been fortunate to date some very
feminine women and they've just done
those things because that's how they
wanted to behave you know I've also
dated some women who are less feminine
they didn't but um the ones that were
really dear to my heart were the ones
who who did those things and like you
said they are very very simple things
what do you feel like that women are the
most clueless about
well I think a lot of it is
um
the feeling that they need to be there
it needs to be a fight with the man the
whole time you know I mean I was dating
a British girl a few years ago and every
conversation was a battle like she felt
like all the time she had to get one up
on me she had to be the the dominant one
you know in a sort of a girl boss kind
of a way and um and there were times she
could be feminine as well there were
times when she slipped into that into
that space but
um in the end I just thought this is
just not an energy that I want to deal
with it's just not an energy that I feel
is is Pleasant
yeah yeah you know so
um can I ask you to be more specific
um because I like to have like this I do
this with my boys sometimes when they
trying to speak to a girl I send I tell
them to write a text
as in my my boys my friends my guys okay
if they ever ask me for advice on uh
girls women how what what should I say
in the first message and I type it for
them they're usually they're quite
successful can you do that for the girls
what would you be me what would you
write on her behalf to get a man to like
her from that first message
well I think it's different we talk
about like sliding into DMS on social
yeah how do you slightly how would you
advise a woman like literally what would
you say to introduce yourself and get a
tick tick tick I'm a fan of commenting
on stories and I think this goes for
either uh on Instagram I think this goes
for either gender actually but I think
if a girl starts following the guy and
then she maybe comments on something she
maybe makes an observation about
something you know like oh I really like
that suit you're wearing or you know
like like I really like the way that you
know if the guys say the guy's giving a
presentation you know he's filming
himself at work he's giving a
presentation I really like the way you
did that that was very cool making some
sort of observation about him I think
would be a good way to initiate the
conversation I mean I have to caveat
this by saying of course it's slightly
different this way around because guys
are going to judge or beauty so the
first thing he's going to do is go and
have a look at her feed and see you know
is she attractive so that's going to
play a huge part but I do think
personalizing it a bit yeah
um and and starting a conversation
talking about something that the guy's
doing is probably better than just
sliding in and going
I
had a question that I asked earlier um I
think you were gone for what are things
that women can do actively to support
men on their mission
so they can they can take
[Music]
it's weird now normally I could talk
without it they can look at a situation
and try to do things proactively I love
nothing more than a woman that's
proactively helping me hey I noticed
this I wash your clothes I fold it and
put them here you know and that's not to
be you know sexist or anything like that
but like a woman that's proactively
trying to help you it is a big deal a
woman that can again sit down and have a
conversation with you you know is a big
deal but you're talking about helping
right yeah well because we always hear
about how
um like you want to be a man's support
system but I think right we don't hear
often like specifics on how to do that
so being really really helpful in that
regard being able to run an Aaron form
or be that you know but I think what's
most important especially for a high
achieving man a high like a high power
man just be his [__] piece man he's
dealing with stress all day he's taking
major risk be the peace you know rub is
back you know do you need anything just
tell them how much especially if he's
helping you in some way or even even if
it's not full charge family house kids
just the you know he's gonna he should
be paying for most of the meals like I
believe in general it's completely
traditional generals I don't believe in
spitting splitting bills I will never
split a dinner bill with a woman and
don't open a [__] door in front of me
but it's those things that you tell him
you appreciate that when it that's when
it goes back to being the hero that's
what makes doing it so worth it so
proactively looking for things to help
him hey I saw that I saw the window the
mirrors in your bathroom had [__] all
over them so I did them for you
little simple [__] because what's real
really so hard for men nowadays is that
look I don't have one of my tenants from
one of my apartment buildings call me up
and say hey Justin you know I really
appreciate you giving me a place to live
if I hit a construction schedule the
customer doesn't come up from Costco
doesn't say you know what we really
appreciate you hitting that schedule
so it's a very thankless life for a man
right as it can be for a woman but
when you're doing these things for a
woman especially when you care about
even this little things like dinners or
trips like if y'all are together right
just telling him how much you appreciate
how hard he's working and acknowledging
the benefit that you're getting will
make him turn circles for you incredible
do you feel like lack of
original people not taking spirituality
seriously is playing a huge role in why
relationships are not working because I
feel like everything we just discussed
now not being combative being submissive
um helping out
um it's all like for me I'm a Christian
it's all in the Bible and I know this
generation doesn't really read the Bible
as much so do you feel like that plays a
role to why people are so clueless of
what it means to be a good wife or a
good husband because I sorry I used to
be one of those very combative people
just always argumentative very toxic it
wasn't until I started to read my Bible
that my whole mindset of what it meant
to be feminine completely shifted and
changing I feel like I've made so many
improvements in my femininity and I
would want women to know the same thing
and would you agree are you like you
know a spiritual in that aspect well
first of all I think a big problem that
we see is that people are trading out
spirituality for practicing religion
whether you believe or not Christianity
particularly in my opinion is the reason
that Society developed in such a way
that it did it gave a very positive
framework for people to live their lives
and they did so and for that reason we
were able to be organized men stopped
acting like caveman you know they still
acted on some Primal things but by and
largely it's what created order and
Order creates the ability to create
strong Society amen as we lose that it
begins to get a little belligerent right
um
I don't feel very
I feel like Christianity is in a bad
place and the reason I think
Christianity is in bad place is because
it doesn't have the backbone to stand up
for itself the way Islam does
in regards to what we're allowing to
have happen in the churches right and
for that reason people are
disenfranchised because they feel the
disingenuousness and the two the kind of
the two-sidedness of Christianity I wish
Christianity would stand up for what it
actually believes in more I agree and I
think people will respect that and get
behind it in a different way and I think
that's why you see Islam doing so well
right now this is not me saying I'm
going to go to Islam you know I grew up
in the south in Louisiana in America I
live in Miami now and it is a [__] show
in both places
um
I do believe that the basis of
Christianity which is very close to
Islam by the way is the way for
societies to live and function
coherently organized and safely and I
think that those values if instilled
into men and women can be very very
helpful in the success of society
families and children that are coming up
yes amen yeah yeah I would co-sign that
I mean I think that
um not just in in terms of being
submissive in a relationship but just
the whole fabric of society since
Christianity has been eroded which has
been going on I mean as you see you
could say it's accelerated recently but
it's been going on really for you know
half a century or so like since the
second world war you know
um organized religion in this country
started to decline and people didn't buy
into it in the same way that they used
to and that really I think is at the
root of all of these societal problems
that we're seeing amen I did a podcast
in a church today you did a podcast in
the church in a church because it's not
a church anymore
because they're abandoned they're having
to repurpose these buildings there's one
for sale right now it's a hundred and
seventy seven thousand dollars on the
market right now for sale it's been it's
like it's deserted why did you feel like
Christianity sorry to shift the topic
but why did you feel like Christianity
no longer has a backbone I personally
feel like people have taken the God will
forgive you no matter what too literally
and maybe that's why you know it has no
more backbone because people are going
directly against what's in the actual
word
like there's no such thing as gay
preachers sorry yep it's not because I
hate gay people that's not what the
religion is people feel that you know
what bothers people more than anything
in the world it's not the truth it's
deceit
there's deceit in Christianity right now
they're putting gay flags on churches I
just saw one the other day crazy it's
it's yeah and look it's not because I
hate gay people I don't hate gay people
at all
but it's not Christianity it's not the
more it's not what's in the [__]
manual which is the Bible right now
if we if you have that situation
anywhere else in your life
if you have a job somewhere or somebody
makes a promise to you or somebody does
something for you and and then literally
they don't do that you will feel deceit
it's not it's not the truth that bothers
people it's to seek always
so that's what I think is failing and
then we've created a society in which
from a legal perspective we're not in
America you can literally have children
out of wedlock and cash flow from it the
laws are set up in a way I I said this
I'll show you I think yesterday
it's when I used to grocery shop I would
be in line I'd see a woman sitting there
with six [__] kids she'd have two
buckets one where it was a it was a
Louisiana Purchase Card she's paying in
food stamps
the man's gone there's multiple baby
daddies same woman you know she left
them because he cheated okay well now
you have four baby daddies right and now
I'm paying for it with tax money
you know like the incentive to to have a
nuclear family is gone and they're
pitting men and women against each other
you could make a Facebook account
tomorrow that says you're a 23 year old
white male in the new or blackmail it
wouldn't matter the things that they
would put in your face to give you
emotion would be completely different
just based off what you put in there
and why does that make sense well with
technology maybe we need men's backs a
little bit less women are coming up
women are not stupid they're good in the
workplace I'm not saying that they're
incredible my my best people or some of
them are women
but what do you get when you break the
nuclear family up two people playing
taxes
how you said your highest paid employee
is a woman yeah
um is she married yes and how does she
like navigate that
look they have a very traditional
relationship I don't want to speak on
that too much because they're very close
to me and it's it is work stuff but
she's a very intelligent woman she's a
true Pro she's really good at what she
does he's been doing his job for a long
time they've been married for God I
think 30 years you know they have very
one one of her other Sons worked for me
he's actually in accounting
um
and they're the most based family I've
ever met in fact in a lot of ways
um I think that they're closer to me
than even like that woman is closer to
me my own mother is you know we're tight
I talk to her every day
so um does your husband make more than
her
I don't know you don't know and I don't
want to speculate I'm close to him no
I'm just wondering because you're you're
talking about man that's very new by the
way oh her like I don't think she's ever
made this much money
[Music]
she's worth every [__] penny yeah
because when you were talking earlier
you're saying it's going to be hard for
me because I'm tall and like I also like
make a lot of money yeah but she's 30
years into a marriage they're past that
you know you know when I really think
the pressure is on 25 to 45. she's past
that like honestly I think she does it
means she's curious like like what
traits do you think in my position I
should be looking for
traits in a man yeah you know you know
you already know what you're looking for
yeah no but I'm just curious do you
think like relationships can never work
when the girl out earns the guy
I think it's very hard yeah I think it's
very very hard because that because
that's the provide part right
you know maybe he can protect you but
you already know that he's a man it's
not you already know you can't whoop his
ass right yeah so then where's the
provide thing
and that's why I don't really believe in
power couples in that way now somebody
could have status and they could have
double status but most often it's not
going to work and a lot of times the
power couples are like famous people
it's not really a power couple I
actually have a friend of mine
his um
his wife got a really solid uh real
estate job and ever since she's been
making that big money they've had
problems and like they're living in
different houses and like this is a big
strong masculine handsome man and just
it just [__] it I have a question sorry
just quickly I'm 23 and I would love to
be married by like 25. I think that's a
great goal by the way thank you women
push that out way further yeah because I
don't want to like let go of my prime
years so what steps do you think I
should take to actually get to that
place where by 25 I'm married
I'm 23 by the way
yeah so
that's probably not going to happen like
right because you're going to at least
date for two years no hear me out yeah
like mathematically that's going to be a
tough tough one right yeah and then you
have to understand too is a lot of times
that people set goals they don't
understand all about like things they're
gonna have to hurdle that's why I think
that trying like I love what you're
doing because you might miss it and get
married at 27 right I like that I like
that from you I feel like you're very
Bass by the way oh thank you very much
I I think that being the right kind of
fabric
okay and what does that look like
everything I was I was speaking to her
about earlier okay as far as like not
having the skin out there it kind of
stay up to date on on what's going on
the news
be conservative especially if you want a
man like any man
that's working his ass off is probably
conservative because he doesn't want to
give all his tax money away he doesn't
want to hear about people crying because
he's getting banged every day while he's
winning he's getting arrows putting his
back people are stabbing him in the back
people are not paying them he's got
employees quitting he doesn't want to
hear any crybaby [__] right real men
have real [__] problems and so they
don't like it when people cry just to
get extra when they've done all the damn
work so if you can do that and then do
the things I was talking about earlier
about appreciate hey man listen I really
appreciate that weekend you just gave me
I wouldn't have had it because of you
and it's because you worked so hard and
I really respect and admire how hard you
work to make my life better I love being
with you those kinds of things and then
showing it with little acts of love you
ain't got to clean the whole house if
you don't want to just just
wash a load of clothes or wipe off the
cabinet so just show you have that care
leave on that note go kill it today I'm
so proud of you that's the kind of [__]
that makes a man never want to leave a
woman because he's getting return on
investment of all that hard work that
he's putting into you
I think if you want to make a man stay
make them feel appreciated all the time
I think it's a big step it's those
little it really is those little things
yeah it really is yeah we don't want a
whole lot a whole lot just just
acknowledge the fact that I'm out there
fighting dragons for you you know what
I'm saying and then I'm taking all that
energy and all that pain and everything
I had to risk to be able to bring it
back to you and spend a weekend with you
in the Bahamas like just make it known
that you appreciate that so much you
know and he is happy to do it at that
point yes ma'am you know
um you have a lady friend I might start
a new channel just doing this
yeah what's up usually people talk about
men and women shouldn't be friends you
mentioned the lady I agree with that in
your life okay so why why can she be
your friend and you said that you've got
women in your life that I've got they're
all like you've got girlfriends that do
bring value to your life so do you have
friends that are girls
and would you like that as well would
you like your wife to have male friends
no no no guy friends so you don't rate
that there's no man listen there's no
man find a guy with a a girlfriend
that's 300 pounds good luck and there's
no look any guy that's your friend who
wants to sleep with you so like if if me
and you were friends I'll just and you
and like I'm I want to [__] you
I'm gonna be nice long enough to stick
around while you complain about your
boyfriend and give me all the answers to
the test then when we do all those
perfect things I don't personally Run
the game like that because I think
that's [__] [__]
but I'm just hypothetically telling you
if a guy's sticking around he wants to
be your friend he wants to sleep with
you what about the lady that you were
just talking about which one friend that
you mentioned that you know they're
quite close to you
yeah she's got a husband do you want to
see her dude first of all she's 50
something years old okay so there's 20
years between the age that but yeah I
mean and and I'll tell you something
I got blessed with it thank you I got
blessed with a gift if I sign your
paychecks I do not want to sleep with
you
so maybe like a woman no I can have a
business
yeah but I wouldn't hang out outside of
work okay like when I took all of them
to Florida her husband was there okay
but yeah and he's and he's one of the
main ones I want to know is coming right
okay because I'm not I would never
disrespect him I love I love that man of
death okay I make him a part of I
include him okay so so there's dynamics
that you can work with where men and
women can be friends then oh man I she's
one of my favorite people in the whole
world okay so that's good so generally
but you have to create a certain Dynamic
that is right and then you can actually
do yeah I don't like it to be within
range I don't particularly like to hire
women don't particularly like why I'm
not no you didn't let me finish the
sentence she's ready
yeah let me finish the sentence I don't
particularly like to hire women that are
close enough in age to me okay that
there could be a thing
all right you know what I'm saying
because it can like look dude I'm the
boss
I'm coming in I'm dressed nice I'm
taking control of every situation we
have over 200 employees like now bro I
don't need it so if you're an attractive
woman then you might as well just say
bye-bye to having guy friends even if
you're older
say again so if you're an attractive
woman even if you're older you should
say bye bye if you're a woman at all I
think you just need to understand if
your man comes to you and says listen I
don't want you to have God friends you
need to truly understand that any guy
that's acting like his friend like like
your friend wants to sleep with you okay
and every other man knows it okay and
anybody that says otherwise is a liar so
what if the man then let's say you're in
a relationship and your guy friend wants
to create a relationship with your
partner because he wants to still be
your friend even if though you're young
as a woman is that big yeah so I'm
around look my friends have me and
Andrew are very close
I've been on sitting at countless tables
with Andrew and Tristan Tate and
Sterling Cooper and they all bring
beautiful stunning women to the table
the only thing that happens when they
get up to pee is I ask them how in the
hell did you land him
that is your job as a friend
you know that's snake [__] I I would
leave my girl in my bank card with the
Tates any day of the week
okay because they and here's why and
this goes back to ethics before you need
them
this happens all the time two guys are
friends
they've been friends 20 years one of
them gets married
the relationship starts getting Rocky
right they get separated
the woman starts whether it be spider
scorn or whatever
the only man that she really has a
relationship outside of her husband was
that friend that dude sleeps with that
girl and he ruined a 20-year marriage I
mean friendship ruined it burnt It To
The Ground they'll never be friends
again why because he's not in enough
abundance he didn't have the ethics to
be in enough abundance to be so proud of
the fact that he could tell there's no
way in hell I have told some seriously
beautiful women to [__] off in my
Instagram inbox so me and Andrew and
Tristan can laugh about it because they
slept with that girl three years ago
there's no [__] way we take pride in
it the only way it's easy to take pride
in it as a man to be in serious
abundance because they don't date
slouches I mean tens and I'll give you
an example there's this girl she
messaged me one time in my inbox
and I'm like hey Andrew I noticed that
you followed this girl he said yeah I
dated her three years ago she's a
[__] perfect got it Andrew said
you're a [__] bye boom that girl has
never had somebody reject her like that
ever
and I like it and so does he because
it's funny it's fun yeah it's fun
because because what other and and
that's why you have to like when we talk
about like you have to have standards in
your life standards for the women in
your life standards for their friends in
your life I don't want a friend that's
not abundant in money and women
because what it'll do what happened to
man B that slept with his friend's
ex-wife
he would he he was not a bad man he was
a desperate man
and he was a desperate man because he
did not have the ethics to put himself
in abundance so he was in a desert for
women so he had to do so we had a drink
and he ruined something that he could
have had the rest of his life
and he ain't got many friends so as a
single woman
given everything that has been said
about how women that know your friends
they're jealous of you that they said
that right in general
isn't it really a good idea for a single
woman to actually have more male friends
so that they can tell her that I think
it's a great idea for a single woman to
have married friends
fine so okay so that's there's like
little special married male friends no
okay married female no okay I don't I
don't think a woman should have male
friends like at 12 zero but
if she wants to lie to herself if she if
she's like hey this guy's my friend but
he wants to sleep with me that's one
thing especially if you're single okay
so what do you what if you get a
boyfriend and he's like nah bro then if
you really love him it won't even be a
problem to get rid of that guy friend
because then it goes back to base and
sit down and have a real conversation
you know in your heart that God wants to
[__] you like come on you do you do know
if you went up to him you're like hey
let's have sex right now I think some of
my guys will find that very strange
they'll be like are you on drugs yeah as
they're like okay
yeah but I was gonna say I asked because
I have a lot of uh male friends he wants
to sleep with you no wait wait but I
believe that
there's almost like expect at least
whilst I'm single right there's a
sacrifice that I make ways like I'll
create very straight boundaries because
I believe there's a lot of value in me
being especially because I've got
sisters I don't have brothers right I
think there's a lot of value me having
that male energy because my guy friends
are the ones that kind of give me the
right advice and guide me into things
like for example you mentioned of
um don't dress too provertedly that's a
little bit much don't you know like
things like this they kind of put me in
check because they can there are the way
I can reflect my my femininity on
something that is not just a woman's
feminities like a femininity from a
man's perspective because obviously if
you're not in a relationship and if you
don't have your dad around for whatever
reasons or if you don't have brothers
then where do you get that sort of
source and knowledge that sometimes only
a man can give you
well I mean if you were friends with
some couples that that would be the
ideal like what are you saying a
beautiful thing yeah yeah because that
way you would get some of that from the
the mailing a successful one at that
yeah but you would also get some
exposure to a successful relationship as
well which is kind of like you know
Pearl often talks about you know
learning learning life skills and stuff
I mean that would be the ideal way to do
it so and that's also another really
great way to find the right man because
what will happen is is he's got a friend
that's looking too
and that's how people get put together
you know you meet them in the right
atmosphere oh yeah they all came over
you should come over Jim's coming over
blah blah blah Jim's a stud boom married
bam you're in the atmosphere successful
relationship
so I don't think it's a bad place I'm
going to break up a few friendships
today
[Laughter]
and they're like damn I thought I had
her never did I already know which one I
wanted to be but all you happy I mean
not speculating on all your friendships
but like if you kind of on some level
know the guy wants to sleep with you
that that friendship is not equal is it
it's disingenuous yeah I don't know I
feel like
I mean
I I enjoy sports I enjoy a lot of the
things that you normally do with the
boys right so
I almost kind of I don't sacrifice
anything I just simply I'm very rigid in
who I am and how I interact with men
like for example I always say if there's
a um if I'm having uh you know I'm
sitting down with my friend there is a
guy if you do something to me that is
not something that you do to another guy
then I'm like that's not cool like boys
don't sit down hugging each other for
example things there's boundaries and
that allows me to kind of like take out
the things that I do need the value that
there is in knowing a man on a personal
level rather than it always just be
about work do you get what I mean yeah
but I think you're getting a little bit
lost between the gap between your
expectation and your reality right
because your reality is that he does
want to touch you in a different way
than he wants to touch that other man
and you're setting it I promise you
Brothers you are disgusting yeah they
are do that we're friends yeah but but
you're believing it but you know in your
heart it's not true no to be honest I do
know and um I mean because of course
like duh so yeah so when he does that
and you're giving him that like you
might be some of them show it uh but he
did he touched you in the wrong way no
I'm saying I'm saying like
allow that to happen like I haven't
for example yeah but he's just trying
not to set off your creep radar yeah
he's just trying not to say creep radar
well then you should cover yourself up
he's paying attention to how you're
dressing he might be trying to groom you
to be wifey you never know I'm just
saying tell me that but like for example
like with my guy friends a lot of the
good things that I like to hear is when
they complain to me about the girls that
they're dealing with and through that I
can understand oh okay yeah obviously
you don't like that the same way that
we're having a conversation right now do
you know how much knowledge we can take
out of hearing a man is speaking to a
man on a personal level about these sort
of things yeah that's what I but what
I'm saying is like this experience right
now is obsolete really it's not going to
happen a whole lot but what I think
troying out on the head is that if you
can have a relationship let's say with a
girlfriend and spend time around the
couple that man is giving a married
relationship which means he's successful
at it right hopefully he's providing
protecting and they're together so you
get to see it quite up close and
personal and then you get to see the
dynamic of both which I think is also
really important and it also puts you in
an atmosphere to be like them which
would in this case be success because
you would have a husband or a partner or
whatever two would an environment really
also want to do it even though he's
called yeah dude listen if I can go to
my girl and be like yo let's have sex
with your girl I'm down don't let me
[__] you he wants to sleep with you
as well but the frame is completely
different
the frame's completely different he does
not he does but he's not really your
friend he's there and you can get good
advice from a successful man at the
kitchen table or when you're sitting at
the cabinet and she's cooking and y'all
are talking and drinking wine and he
comes in and you can ask his opinion
right in front of his wife it's a
different scenario okay so you need the
right frame yeah that's fine yeah that
makes sense
I like that
answer boys unless you're putting money
in my pocket with doing business you
can't be my friend
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible